let's talk economics huh so we're
talking about civil war earlier i saw
this tweet from matt kors he says
prepare for a crash and he's referencing
jim cramer saying why we're buying
stocks heading into wednesday's big fed
decision
you know what this sounds like to me the
federal reserve oh the federal reserve
is trending let's see if they if they
raise rates
when when when the tv tells you to buy
they're like it's not a recession buy
it's because the rich people are
offloading and the break is gonna happen
yeah he made some crazy calls in 2008
that were absolutely wrong and have
obliterated people's personal finances
look it's like claire stearns get a
bunch of it this is probably seriously
that's what we did
this is uh this is from yesterday
morning
every stock in the s p 500 is red right
now oh my gosh so when they're like no
no we're buying right now with the fed's
decision it's going to raise rates and
tank the market
now i don't know man the challenge is
raising interest rates to try and deal
with inflation
what else do you do do you just let uh
what do you do well it's difficult right
because this is what they always do
every single time the stock market is
declining they print a bunch of money to
artificially inflate the price of stocks
but of course that
in the long run as we just saw inflates
the cost of everything else so with
inflation out of control i have no idea
what they're even going to attempt to do
we're just building better yeah they're
just building back better baby it's
almost like it's almost like they're
gonna have to reset things in some some
way
it's almost like we have to live in the
pods and eat the bugs let's talk about
this it's going well it's building back
better uh property price prices plunge
by the 20 across parts of the us
we got red uh real estate firms compass
and redfin announced layoffs as housing
markets slows and then we get coinbase
dropping eighteen percent of it's down
the crypto market we get because crypto
took a major hit but apparently what
they're saying is we are entering a
recession this is what they're saying
you know they didn't have to do this
but it appears we're entering a
recession housing markets getting hit
stock markets getting hit
building back better apparently means
wiping out all of the gains of the past
two years driving gas prices up to five
bucks a gallon making sure you can't
work and sending billions of dollars to
uh to ukraine to fund war hold on to be
fair to be fair it's going to go up
to way more than five dollars a gallon
oh yeah that's a good point yeah yeah
maybe maybe seven by august i mean i'm
already where i live in palm beach
california we're like 639 so we're
already at
what a sophisticated and well-run state
i hope they tell florida what kind of
policies they have right
the only thing saving me is that good
weather whatever that's that's about it
i love it i love it klaus rob told me
that i will own nothing and be happy and
that's how i feel right i was like i
already own nothing when you're gonna
make me happy that's how i feel i feel i
feel happy right now this this biden
loves me i'm a stupid mexican i can't
think for myself i can't vote for myself
i i can't figure out how to go get a
voter id and i'm poor someone's going to
keep going oh my money just sucks my
bank account is horrible i have nothing
to own nothing to show for myself tim i
am so happy well let's just go back it
only applies i love it it only applies
okay the cloud schweinsteiller white
supremacist cops are hunting me
everywhere i go and it's just it's just
going oh no no it only applies if you're
poor
i am poor tim oh
drew well i'm not surprised
better i am poor i give my money to
zilinski i donate religiously what is
going on right now i left the christian
church and i went to the church of
zielinski i give like tithing to him
every single month listen i'm part of
the cult tim buy an electric car yeah
right it's only sixty thousand dollars
thousand dollars
email or email email musk i tried to get
one but it didn't work so i'm trying to
email biden to get one next and it's
it's it will get it sounds like you
don't want to build back batteries i am
building back better that's what you
guys don't understand you guys are all
the crazy ones every single one of you
in this room i i am the same this is
such a big
you guys didn't get the update i have
the most recent update the new thing the
new thing you guys don't even know what
it is you know the thing i just i want
to mention one thing i find this
hilarious right because you'll have like
talk show hosts like stephen colbert and
other people on the left who will say if
you're worried about gas prices just get
an electric an electric car when like
obviously that's ridiculous if someone's
having trouble affording gas they can't
afford an electric car but also
it's not as if having an electric car
exempts you from the widespread economic
consequences of high gas prices food's
going to get more expensive dude energy
costs are going to go away for the
blackout charge that car wait for the
burnout to blackout
right now yeah they're like well i have
an electric car tampons who needs
tampons right no wasn't that a story
yeah tampon shortage
but but but women could just use rags
can't they yeah yeah yeah drew i'm not a
lady about that right drew you have
experience with it
i'm the greatest woman you guys have
ever seen don't you guys know it takes a
great man to be a real woman
thomas and freaking taylor like didn't
what happened with her with the
skateboarding hey hey don't disrespect
leah thomas let's just keep it on
economic collapse the shoulders only
otherwise we're gonna we're kind of
going crazy they just had to put well
they had to put a hold on all women's
products until we can figure out what a
woman is exactly okay it's the end of
the world we might as well enjoy it
right we got mass layoffs
and it's happening in the housing market
first crypto is kind of like it's its
own thing uh i'm not selling crypto you
know i i think crypto's going down the
same as most things are going down
but
what's going to come next with high gas
prices with a recession
i hope you all are getting prepared
i don't know exactly what that means do
you buy 30 years of the beans i don't
know don't look at me all i know is
it is gonna get worse
because they're telling us it's gonna
get worse because they said you will own
nothing you know what nothing means
nothing owning nothing means you won't
have a can of beans that's right so it
says when you're hungry you might find
yourself in a walmart parking lot
fighting with agnes over that last can
well but there's this really smart guy
who told me bread lines are a good thing
because it means you have community yeah
red lights was that birds bloodlines are
a good thing it's like well that's
really easy to say when you have like
three houses right
i have three loaves of bread one for
each house dude when he went he so he's
hilarious he went to the ussr on his
honeymoon and i'm not kidding you one of
the things he said praising the soviet
government was that there were
inexpensive puppet shows
i just want that to sink in that is a
little he's like well look the puppet
shows were very unexpensive they've got
gulags but a puppet show it's cheap you
go there you get to see the puppets talk
with each other it's charming quite
frankly did he really say this yes he
said they had cheap he was going on with
a list of all the wonderful things that
were happening in the ussr and one of
them was he he praised these cheap
puppet shows he's like the only camera
is like a dollar fifty you get to watch
a puppet show it's incredible what
every other developed nation has cheap
puppet shows but the united states why
is that why aren't we talking blackrock
is gonna own everything man including
the [ __ ] vr that's gonna be the gulag
entertainment is puppet shows by bernie
sanders you guys i think i'm kidding
look up the ussr and bernie sanders in
puppet shows look it up all i know is oh
if anyone who's kindness out of talk was
in the gulag i'm your boy because we're
smoking like arnold bernie bernie is
like in we got to figure this
out they have cheap puppet shows and i'm
and there's the other guy's just in
there he's like i was i was i was just
watching the simpsons
can you tell me how to get how to get i
thought somebody street can you guys
know the shawshank redemption yes
you know like red he's like the go-to
guy to get your stuff i could picture
tim being read in the gulags when they
come tim's gonna be like the go-to don't
give him to get your stuff to get you
connected to whatever you need
absolutely not true tim's the guy i'm
going to be you're going to be shadows
minding my own business now you'll be
the guy no i won't be
no
i'll be just sitting in the back and
someone walk up to me and i'll be like
don't open your mouth keep walking i
could see sheamus using his i'm not
going to go
is this some guy
this is a lot of gold reference do you
think they're going to let us know i was
going to say a prison wallet but that's
another discussion
i thought you're going to make a potato
reference or something i just want to
say by the way with this inflation stuff
i mean i've got a pot of gold so i'm
fine you're set yeah for you
i'm just kidding i don't i don't have
any assets
right
so yeah but if i did those would also be
crashing i'm serious
if i did those would also be crashing
what what are the consequences of this i
mean what do we do and what is the
federal reserve going to do i'm really
i'm faster raise interest rates
because inflation is going insane yeah
and uh
you know i suppose the real issue is
they could encourage more production
we could do more energy development here
at home
instead they're just like me
you know but then people will own
something and not be happy exactly
they'll own stuff and be unhappy i mean
it is true owning stuff makes you
unhappy true we talked about it they did
a a survey a test on people a study
where they said if you complete this
questionnaire you'll get a free t-shirt
one group got to choose between two
different shirts one group was just
given a shirt the group that got to
choose was unhappy because they were
like oh i picked the wrong color i
should have picked the other one the
people were just giving a shirt like
cool free shirt got a shirt yeah it was
the choice that actually made them all
right i'm gonna be happy in the pod then
yeah
they're not gonna let that you choose
they're like there's your pot it's gray
and you're like i like it
it's free huh it's free tell me what you
need i just hope they don't let me
choose what kind of bugs i'm eating
you'll be like i should have chose
crickets these roaches are
gross yeah
crickets are crunchier
little uh uh put a little little tapatio
on them yeah there you go there you go
that's how you do it
the irish food you want irish food
though they're probably serving irish
food oh okay all right yeah
yeah okay then i don't know man i like
uh shepherd's pie i like potatoes every
now and again there's like something
good it's like they make a stew and they
top it with potatoes it's great yeah
that's what they do look all i'm saying
is this
we're we are in a can you guys want to
make all these jokes we are in a
conundrum here but this i mean look this
is one of the uh inevitable consequences
of an economy which is planned and not
just planned but planned by people who
face zero consequences for making
horrible decisions
this is where we are these people have
always been incompetent even
who they look up to in worship can i
make this point
fdr who they look up to in worship this
is the greatest president we ever had
well firstly america had one of these
slowest economic recoveries of any
developed nation coming out of the great
depression but also
he once increased the price of gold by
21 cents and his rationale was
seven three times is a lucky number
that's amazing these were the kinds of
decisions being made for the entire
economy i kind of agree with it
but it's it's not as if we've had it
it's not as if um it's a new phenomenon
that the economy is being run and
controlled by people who have absolutely
no clue what they're messing with
it's just we're seeing some seriousness
with their consequences i think they
know what they're doing because it's
definitely some of them i mean look at
this doesn't it look at some of them i
mean everyone who was responsible for
2008 none of them are held so yeah
they're not held responsible um
it's a broken system but you know who's
who is held responsible is guys like you
know julian assange you know for like
exposing war crimes and those who who
did the war crimes they don't have to
see them they weren't only just
not held responsible they were promoted
they were given a check they were given
bonuses on top of their financial crimes
that they committed against the people
so so what happened there was paved over
the bubble was made bigger and now we're
all just kind of sitting here waiting
for everything to pop as of course we're
getting the first kind of storm incoming
and i think this is one storm of many to
come and i think you know
we talk about the problems i think maybe
we still got a couple more minutes we
could talk about maybe potential
solutions i think one of the best
currencies you could have is social
currency the friends you have the
relationships you have a family
your neighborhood your community i think
focusing on creating pods on
homeschooling your children or is
something that of course will help get
us through these larger storms because
they are coming there's a lot of people
are few you know scared a lot of people
think there's you know resistance is
futile it's not i just i want to let the
record show luke said focus on making
pods
he does want you to live in the podium
just home school
homeschooling
the m1 money supply has shrunk
check it out
from april
i'm sorry from march at 20 what is it 20
trillion 700
okay so
well you can sort of see it no look at
that it dropped by about uh what 40
billion is that maybe that's the 40
billion we gave to ukraine
from march to april
it's like 40 billion out of the money
supply uh but that was like six no no
i'm sorry it was like it's like it's
like 80.
yeah it drops by about 90 actually about
90 billion so uh i wonder if that's
seeing where the recession is coming
because they were just pumping money
into the system trying to keep it going
and they stopped and now everything's
going to fall apart because there's no
real trade happening
there could be bartering i think
bartering is something that people
should
also kind of look into especially when
it comes to having a community having a
network of individuals that could trade
skills that could trade goods that could
trade services uh you know the free
state project i think is is ahead of its
time they do incredible things when it
comes to uh homeschooling they do
incredible things when it comes to
building communities and i and i think
you know the amish did it in their own
particular way there's no reason other
people other communities can't do it
themselves as well and once we start
becoming personally responsible for
ourselves we don't need government
government would become obsolete if
people were just responsible for
themselves as individuals because we
wouldn't need any government
intervention we wouldn't need anyone
stepping in a way we wouldn't need
anyone saying hey we need big government
for this that's going to make the
problem that much worse um the solution
i i think you know we're headed towards
crazy turbulent times but it doesn't
mean that it can't be an opportunity to
to see the good and to build something
better
there it is
[Applause]
you know it's funny because you're right
luke has all these videos where he's
confronting very prominent individuals
and there was one point where people
were like there's no way luke was
actually able to get in front of like
ben bernanke so he must be a fed oh
we did this skit that was really funny
no because like a lot of people were
like you know look without a video where
he's like confronting ben bernanke three
times three times and they're like
there's no way yeah they're like this
guy's a plant
and so then we did a bit where luke's
phone rings and it says ben bernanke and
he's like benny
what's up man he's like yeah i'll come
hang out i'm using disguises and like
fake names and fake press credentials
fake websites and fake emails just to
get into venues and events and like
staying outside literally hours on end
just waiting for one politician to maybe
go this one particular way oh yeah so
i've been i've been working my butt off
but yeah that that nose it's not a real
nose yeah yeah well luke actually look
actually i got the same thing myself uh
when i covered the the uvalde shooting a
bunch of my dms were like isn't that
weird that you just happened to be there
so i'm like i was covering the border in
eagle pass which is like an hour away i
have a car we drove there
i love when people are like isn't it
weird i like yeah like sometimes things
are weird yeah yeah yeah it was weird
like maybe shows
shows a simulation tim is not real he's
not a real person oh yeah
like if everybody knows this in this
room that if you take his beanie off
right now it'll be like robocop
is it a little weird that tim has his
genius
it is true but the point doesn't even
know it no no he doesn't even know that
he's not real no no no i do and the
point is you don't by saying tim you
don't know i do and the point is
by saying yes the people who are
watching
assume that we're all joking but there's
no way to know if it's true or not
so when we tell
they will say it must be a joke and
they're all having a laugh but it's real
yeah that's right actually that's the
scariest thing with security is that
people believe that stuff tim bull is
not real and then
the threats the threats we get aren't
antifa
the people who who common causes
problems are just crazy people
like we actually believe it or not
after everything we've done and after
everything that's happened we've still
had people try showing up here
don't give up and they'll be like i know
that like you get death threats all the
time and like the bomb squad was just
here and the sign says warning we will
shoot intruders but i decided to come
onto your property anyway and i'm like
wow the armed guard deter you what he
did and i'm like that's what we have
them
that's that's crazy out there clout
chasers well i gotta say i mean you know
as i've been talking about civil war for
years
it's it's like
i'm kind of the point where watching the
brett kavanaugh stuff is like
you know i feel that
with what we've been dealing with
that i'm just like if they're when they
don't enforce that that pisses me off
because i'm we're seeing something
similar well i think this kavanaugh
assassination attempt came about a day
after a study was published in the news
which showed that was something like 44
of young democratic men support
political assassinations yep and the
fact that they're not stamping out those
literally illegal protests as an attempt
to sway judicial rulings is a sign to me
that they would like to weaponize these
people who like the idea of
assassination lydia why are we wasting
our time doing that we have to chase
down these moms and dads at the school
board meetings yeah that's that's the
real
real yeah yeah
the real threat are the moms and dads
that don't want their children groomed
and touched yeah exactly those are the
people we got to go out there
that's the real domestic terrorist
terrorism right there independent
journalism
can you believe that that first
amendment is literally the reason why we
have terrorism they believe they could
say whatever they want they believe they
can think whatever they want
and this is going to shock you guys they
think they have the right to own
firearms
and they think they have the right to
own firearms even
while having
bad opinions that hurt my feelings
opinions yeah
i think we hurt your feelings bro i
think we need red flag laws
will that make you feel better
it would
probably help me feel a little bit
better i don't think i'm really going to
be happy until i own nothing yeah yeah
but it'll make me feel like a little
better yeah it'll be partially there
yes
so yeah
excuse me announcement we've said
everything there is to say about
politics with the show is over we are
wrapping tim cast up this is our last
episode
solutions again i talked about my
solutions
the solution is to have klaus schwab
live in studio with tim poole and luke
and sheamus and everybody else that's
the story i would love to
yeah i watched it about the immigration
crisis
people being lied to and all that stuff
i think the immigration thing is just
it's very complex
it's a major sign this country is just
eroded
what's the solution then luke well you
know personal responsibility uh not
participating in the system creating
your own systems creating your own
communities being there for your
families and being an example for
everyone about how to live your life
being not affected by the soy
and by the gmos and monsantos and and
all the other things that are chemically
castrating the future of this country uh
we've been bombarded we've been attacked
i think health is one of the major
aspects that that we should be talking
about more because
essentially you know when you look at
fifth or fourth generational warfare
depends on how you see it the first
thing you have to do is to destroy the
human being and one of the easiest way
to do that is through of course
poisoning that person and i think a lot
of our food is poison i think we need to
really start to understand nutrition and
the importance of of working out
sleeping right getting rid of stress and
more importantly eating right because
almost everywhere you look right now in
our mainline society something is trying
to hurt you for the benefit of someone
else and i think with food it's being
done in such a huge way and we could get
into the debates about seed oils
vegetable oils sugar
gmos
and all these artificial things that are
just added that have been wreaking havoc
and once people are you know unhealthy
physically this leads to people being
unhealthy mentally and there's a big
correlation between the gut and the mind
and i think that correlation um is being
taken advantage of by a lot of powerful
people who are purposefully trying to
get rid of your health who are trying to
attack your gut and trying to of course
make you uh absolutely mentally unstable
and i think a lot of people are mentally
unstable because of the diets that we're
given and told to eat every single day i
think that's very much true and another
aspect of it even aside from the
nutritional elements which i would agree
with you there are some serious concerns
there is to habituate people towards
choosing foods which have a pleasant
taste but no real substance to them
because that habituates a person towards
making decisions based on what is the
most convenient for them and the most
pleasurable and always looking for the
path of least resistance rather than
doing what is actually in alignment with
reality it's drugs they're literally
drugging us through our food supply and
at the same time chemically castrating
us so we can't even reproduce that's the
the basic uh you know byline that i
think is the most important thing to to
talk about most important thing to
promote and you could be an example of
not being affected by it by of course
living your best life being healthy
choosing to eat the right foods choosing
to to actually look into nutrition look
into things like
organs liver and get away from all the
other nonsense out there that absolutely
is destroying your mental physical and
spiritual health there's fluoride in our
water yes yes there is involuntarily
what are you talking about
i caught sheamus drinking chloride and
i'm like look sheamus it was straight
fluoride i ordered it from my dentist i
was like yeah let me just do some shots
just no that's that's very bad for you
yeah that will you will die is it well
that actually kill i was just i was
making fun of luke because i've never
had fluoride but luke kind of
i think another issue too with this
generation is we have a generation of
parents that have been convinced through
big pharma that if you have a boy or
girl and you know she has a little bit
too much energy just put him on pills
exactly on pills no no no they give him
a doctor
the doctor tried to do that with my mom
i'm glad that my mom's old school
salvador and she was like i'm gonna just
give the kid this kid the [ __ ]
chocolate you know but
all the diets have so much sugar in them
and they're like oh these kids can't sit
at the desk for eight hours give them
riddles yeah give them their pros it's
not even just sugar it's not even just
the sugar children are not just supposed
to be sitting like that being talked
about all day so there's this massive
breakdown and i talked about this on the
show the other day but matt walsh has
this fantastic film what is a woman but
they're and i think that's wonderful but
there are also so many other definitions
that we no longer agree upon we don't
have any conception of what a child is
if you think it's normal for a kid to be
able to sit in a desk like that for
hours and hours a day you like
fundamentally do not understand children
at all well they want good factory
workers yeah that's where it comes from
the babylonian
the babylon bee came out with a good
article that i just have to share and uh
they wrote an article that's titled
marlborough adds puberty blockers to
cigarettes to make them legal for kids
and
we're not that far away from that kind
of reality
of course there's a satirical website
but but
you know the point is kind of driven
home here about the insanity of the
future of this country that it's being
absolutely uh destroyed from within
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there